you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
a code red for humanity the un's climate
report says human behavior is
unequivocally warming our planet
the ipcc's report says rising
temperatures and changing weather
patterns are to blame for extreme
weather events and that nowhere is safe
but there is some room for optimism
we'll be looking at how we can fix this
starting with reducing our methane
emissions
[Music]
hello and welcome to an extended daily
climate news show on a day described as
a code red for humanity that's after the
un's climate change body said for the
first time that it was unequivocal that
humans have made the world hotter and
with it come warnings of even more
intense and more frequent heat waves an
increase in heavy rainfall and more
droughts
the study by the intergovernmental panel
on climate change provides governments
with scientific information so they can
develop their climate policies
and with less than three months until
the cop 26 talks in glasgow it said the
report is a reality check for global
leaders our climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter reports
as wild weather rages around the world
a landmark u.n climate report has
delivered a confident and frightening
verdict
human behavior is unequivocally warming
our planet driving many of these extreme
conditions un says this is a code red
for humanity and there is nowhere to
hide
what we have found is that in every
region in the world
climate and weather extremes have
changed because of human influence
and um
this is particularly striking for heat
waves so heat waves have increased in
their frequency and intensity
around the world
and
will also continue to increase no matter
no matter if we stop warming at 1.5 or 2
or or higher degrees of warming
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change says that many of the
consequences of global warming like
rising sea levels are already
irreversible
but immediate dramatic cuts and
emissions could still help us avoid the
worst scenarios
that's exactly the aim of a crucial
climate summit being held in glasgow
later this year called cop 26 viewed by
many as a last chance when you're
negotiating and you're trying to push
countries to do more how helpful is it
to have this really solid science behind
you
it's critical it reduces any ambiguity
it
it removes any
wiggle room underpinning everything in
in science and providing solidly backed
um arguments and and statements is
absolutely essential in terms of
narrowing the conversation to um what
needs to be done rather than debating
whether we are at crisis point
excuses are vanishing but cop 26 is
still in a precarious position
advisers directly involved in the
negotiations tell sky news that there is
now a huge effort underway to resolve
sticking points that threaten the summit
mainly over how to phase out coal and
end fossil fuel subsidies as host the uk
government is feeling the pressure it's
a wake-up call and i think people should
understand from this that unless we get
to grips with climate change now uh
humanity is facing catastrophe i i think
it's as stark as that and that's why all
countries need to come forward and
that's the message that i'm going to
continue to deliver as i speak to
governments around the world
the un report could not have been
clearer about what is at stake
climate change does not respect borders
time or the absence of global political
will
the future of our planet depends on the
decisions our leaders make now
hannah thomas peter sky news
well catherine of topsy joins me now so
katharina break down for us then in more
detail the main points of this report
yeah plenty to digest here anna so let's
look at some of that details as you say
well uh this report shows how human
influence has warmed the climate at a
rate that is unprecedented in the last
2000 years affecting every region across
the globe you can see here the changes
in global surface temperature over that
time and since 1850 there's been a
dramatic rise in global temperatures due
to human and natural factors and the
ipcc report estimates that that human
element is responsible for around 1.1
degrees celsius of warming from 1850
until now that is greater than
previously thought and every increase
makes a difference and this shows what
would happen to global temperatures
depending on how much the climate
changes and this chart here on the left
is where temperatures are now and to to
the right these are where temperatures
uh these are the temperatures we can
expect with two degrees of global
warming and remember we're already more
than halfway there and again every
region is affected but particularly the
arctic and the antarctic so the big
question is why greenhouse gas emissions
are one of the biggest factors and every
tonne of carbon dioxide that is released
adds to warming as this chart shows and
in terms of projections this is the best
case scenario in terms of missions these
are very low levels of emissions in the
future and even with them we can expect
to reach 1.5 degrees celsius of warming
in the next 20 years and that's the
legacy of global warming from the
industrial period until now which leaves
us with irreversible changes including
sea level rise up to half a meter and
possibly a summer with no sea ice in the
arctic within the next 30 years uh you
know and these are as a report full of
quite bleak forecasts but we can take
some positivity and an element of hope
out of it uh that
we can still make a difference that with
profound and deep cuts to emissions by
governments
we can limit and avoid the worst
possible impacts of climate change and
possibly
even see some of those effects reversed
in the future katarina thank you well we
now know the costs of doing nothing but
the question remains who's prepared to
pay up to end the fossil fuel era well
the committee on climate change
estimates that reaching net zero
emissions by 2050 could cost the uk
around one to two percent of gdp that's
roughly equivalent to about 50 billion
pounds each year by 2050.
well in a moment i'll speak to our
international affairs editor dominic
waghorn first let's bring in our
political correspondent rob powell and
rob does this report put extra pressure
on the government here to meet its
climate change commitment and is it
clear how that will be paid for
yes it does put extra pressure on and no
it isn't clear at all the uk wants to
see to be seen to be leading by example
in the run-up to cop26 so there will be
extra pressure on them to spell out
exactly how they are going to meet that
net zero target we are expecting a
number of strategy papers in the coming
weeks in early september one of which
will be spelling out the heat and
building strategy there's already
concern among mps though
about the impact of potential higher
energy bills and expensive green
technology like heat pumps and how lower
income households are going to pay for
that there's also a tussle in government
about how you can plug the gap left by a
move to electric vehicles and the lack
of fuel duty so a lot for the government
to get right but they are clear that the
cost of the economy would be more if
they did nothing and dominic some will
say that the priority now is for the
world's biggest emitters to take action
now so what has the response of the
international community been
yeah but i think it's sharpening the
sense of urgency that's already there
not least because these fires and floods
and devastation we've seen uh this year
that there's a sense of trying to make
up for lost time because of the pandemic
but also the denialism of the the trump
era and if you talk to people involved
in the diplomatic process they say there
is a lot going on but there's also a
realization that the science is shifting
it's becoming more pessimistic as this
report bears out and uh the sense that
extreme weather is happening even
earlier and that is potentially
catastrophic so it all eyes will be on
[ __ ] 26 in glasgow and there's this
consensus as you say that the big
emitters have got to reduce their
emissions but also come up with cash to
help those poorer countries do the same
and also deal with the effects of
climate change in the third world and
there's also this challenge it's got to
be a credible effort in glasgow in just
three months time because people have
got to remain hopeful if they give up
hope then the game is over i think the
good news from this report says caterina
was saying was that there is time to
save the planet but it's running out and
a lot more needs to be done
rob powell dominic wagon thanks both
very much indeed
meanwhile the effects of the warming
planet continue to be felt today in
greece the extreme heat wave and
resulting fires have forced thousands to
flee their homes not knowing what will
be left when they return
help has come in the form of an
international band of firefighters and
sky news has spoken to some who are
certain that climate change is to blame
sally lockwood reports from outside
athens
just 16 miles north of athens the fire
has subsided but the bone dry land is
smoldering
and threatens to flare up again
do you want a hand
as we check out the damage a tree
reignites just meters from someone's
home
environmental scientist constantinos
calls it in
but resources are stretched to their
limits
and when it comes to climate change
patience is wearing thin we are very
worried about what we are seeing as we
are every summer actually we're getting
fires as part of our ecosystem in the
mediterranean and in greece but year
after year they're getting all the
worser because of climate change it's
aggravates temperatures summer is
getting drier
and the governments and the services are
getting less and less competent to
manage the phenomena
more than 20 countries have now sent
support to join the firefighting effort
in greece
this team from france arrived on
thursday but have no idea if they'll be
here for weeks even months
[Music]
[Music]
firefighters now find themselves on the
front line in the battle against extreme
weather and with 45 degree heat forecast
here once again
there's a very real fear fires will
return in the coming days
and years
sally lockwood sky news athens
now we're continuing to look at the
ipcc's long-awaited report into climate
change and you can see from this diagram
included in the report global warming is
already affecting every inhabited region
across the globe with human influences
contributing to many changes in weather
and climate extremes well let's talk to
one of the lead authors of the report
now dr yuri rogol who's director of
research at the grantham institute at
imperial college london welcome to you
so a stark warning in this report the
u.n secretary general has called it code
red for humanity
but is there a chance that catastrophe
can be avoided
well the report is very clear we have
warmed our planet today already by 1.1
degrees and that is we are responsible
for that
but we also have important choices to
make today uh depending on how fast we
reduce our emissions over the next
decade we might still be able to limit
warming to 1.5 degrees which is one of
the key limits of the u.n paris
agreement
but if we don't do so then we will be
cruising through those limits
over the next decade and end up with
much higher warming in the next half of
the century
so some hope if we do manage to limit
the rises to 1.5 degrees so how do we do
that what are the solutions
well the report uh really spells out
the clear geophysical requirements that
are needed to limit warming to 1.5 first
of all to stop warming at any level
we need to stop adding co2 to the
atmosphere in technical terms we need to
bring global emissions down to net zero
for each stone that we put in the
atmosphere we have to also remove
somewhere else the same tom of
co2 um then in order to limit warming to
1.5 the amount of co2 that we emit until
we get to net zero is very limited
because we have a carbon budget and uh
in
in the most simplest of terms that means
that if we start on a straight line from
today
we would need to be at net zero uh
around mid-century
but what difference do you think this
report could have on galvanizing change
after all politicians have heard stark
warnings many times in the past they
absolutely have and i think this report
provides a couple of new insights the
first is that
the ipcc for the first time ever uses
the word unequivocally
to attribute the climate change that we
see around us and the impacts the rising
sea level the the increases in extremes
to our human activities and that is of
course because we are living on a
changed planet today
people uh around the globe are
experiencing impacts that they have
never seen in their lifetimes that we
have never seen before in recorded uh
history and i think unfortunately that
experience of what a
world with climate change really means
seems to me a key
aspect of galvanizing actions towards
stopping this increase in global warming
dr yuri rogel thanks very much indeed
in today's other climate news mark's
square in venice has flooded due to
unusual and out of season high water
levels the flooding has been attributed
to a combination of factors exacerbated
by climate change these include rising
sea levels and unusually high tides that
typically only occur in autumn and
winter months
european space imaging has released
these satellite images of the greece
wildfires which can be seen from space
the country has been struck by a number
of wildfires in recent days and one
blaze in athens has subsided
the government has announced it will
provide funding to double the size of a
wind turbine plant in hull to support
the offshore wind industry the 186
million pound investment at the siemens
gamma sur factory will create 200 new
jobs and power 1.3 million homes in
total the government are investing 266
million pounds into offshore wind
turbines across the humber regions
now one of the greenhouse gases which is
often overlooked is methane according to
today's ipcc report it's already warmed
the planet by around 0.3 degrees
reducing our methane emissions from
agriculture and gas production could be
one of the quickest ways to halt the
temperature rise so what is it well
here's an explainer
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well here to explain more is dr anna
jones no relation interim director of
science at the british antarctic survey
welcome to you
so reducing methane could have a big
impact on global warming so how do we do
it which sectors are producing it in the
first place
so about half of the emissions of
methane into the atmosphere come from
anthropogenic man-made sources
um
quite large quantities from the fossil
fuel sector um about equal amounts from
the agricultural sector
and and uh 20 also from waste so
you have to tackle across those
different sectors
and then you can aim to achieve the kind
of reductions which would be very very
good to do
and how do you go about that are there
technologies already available to try to
reduce the methane emissions in those
industries are the solutions out there
well for some of them the answer is yes
um if you look at oil and gas
infrastructure for example
um you can
some methane is lost to the atmosphere
during production process during
extraction during transmission um
that methane is just lost it doesn't do
anybody any good and it warms the
atmosphere so actually if you can reduce
the amount which you're losing through
leaks and poor production processes then
you have an automatic win it would save
um it's obviously good for the planet
which means it's good for all of us but
it's also good for industry because it
um it actually would increase profit
margins in the sense that it's um it's
cost neutral they would be saving money
by not losing the methane to the
atmosphere
and is there enough focus on reducing
methane emissions given what difference
it could make that's a really good
question quite an interesting one in the
scientific community there has been
quite a focus on methane over um
the last
last several years but um
the conversations that i had within the
media and um
you know within within decision makers
policymakers have tended not to consider
methane so much and the focus is on
carbon dioxide and reducing
concentrations of carbon dioxide is
absolutely fundamental to tackling
climate change we have to get
concentrations of carbon dioxide under
control
but the beauty of methane is it gives
you a window
methane um
it's a short-lived gas so if you put
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere it's
there for several hundreds of years if
you put methane into the atmosphere it
actually only has what's called a
lifetime of 10 years so you you can
reduce concentrations of methane in the
atmosphere
relatively quickly so what's good about
me today there are quite a lot of things
that are good about methane but one of
them is that it buys you time you can
you can
by reducing your methane emissions which
is relatively straightforward to do for
some sectors and some sources you gain
some addition
sorry some additional time to tackle
your carbon dioxide emissions dr ana
jones thanks very much indeed well
that's everything from us for today
coming up on tomorrow's show how people
living on rathlin island plan to reduce
emissions and become carbon neutral you
can catch that at the same time here on
sky news see you then
[Music]